voller einsatz ist gefragt sonst steht
man ohne rohstoff karten da doch von
denen braucht man bei tumult royal eine
menge bei dem brettspiel das benjamin
teuber entwickelt hat ist man ein
adliger der sein reich mit statuen
verschönern will
es ist eines von rund 1500 grad spielen
die 2015 in deutschland erschienen sind
gut 20 prozent mehr als noch vor fünf
jahren
für viele ist das spielen ausgleich zum
alltagsstress
ich denke das ist eine sehr bewusste
auszeit ist vielleicht auch ein gewisses
achtsamkeitstraining könnte man schon
fast sagen weil man total im jetzt
gefangen ist und nicht irgendwie an die
nächste woche denkt was man vielleicht
für aufgaben hat oder was gestern
schlecht lief im job sondern dass man
einfach wirklich hier und jetzt
vollkommen fokussiert
seit zwei jahren entwickelte 31 jährige
hauptberuflich spiele am prototyp vom
tumult royal hat er eineinhalb jahre
herumgetüftelt und dabei fast 100
testkunden gespielt irgendwann kommt
dieser moment das man einfach merkt ich
bin jetzt gar nicht mehr in der
entwicklung sondern wir spielen gerade
einfach nur noch macht einfach nur noch
spaß
und dann merkt man jetzt hab ich gerade
diesem moment wo es auch noch spaß macht
und ich entwickele gar nicht mehr und
dann hat man das gefühl vielleicht hier
und da noch ein kleinen feinschliff oder
sowas aber dann merkt man eigentlich das
spiel jetzt live
als weg bereitete entwicklung gilt
benjamins vater klaus täuber sein
brettspiel die siedler von catan
verkaufte sich mehr als 22 millionen mal
weltweit populär ist es auch bei
computer nerds im silicon valley ein
gegenpol zum alltag vor dem bildschirm
selbst facebook gründer mark zuckerberg
outete sich als fan
den grund für den erfolg sehen die
brettspiel experten johannes jäger und
jan cronauer alias hunter und co in der
vielschichtigkeit der deutschen bank
spiellandschaft verstehen die amerikaner
in erster linie was mit ausgeklügelten
mechanismen die wie ein uhrwerk
ineinander greifen muss wenig glück gibt
spieler nicht vorzeitig sterben oder
anderweitig ausschalten können wo
konflikt nicht darin besteht dass man
militärische einheiten oder raumschiffe
oder zombie horden aufeinander hätte bei
youtube präsentieren die beiden seit
fast drei jahren ihre show hunter und
kroon brettspiele tag bestellen sie eine
neue episode ins netz
brettspiele hier findet ihr wirklich
alles rund um das einspielen bord games
tremmel tops kartenspiele kinderspiele
das ganze zeug
sie stellen neuerscheinungen vor
rezensieren spiele und laden andere
youtuber zu ihrem passspiel club 1
für sie sind brettspiele längst mehr als
nur familie unterhaltung
sie sprechen von einer brettspiel kultur
es ist inzwischen auch richtige
beschäftigung für erwachsene oder junge
erwachsene wie man es nennen mag die
gleichwertig steht zu filme gucken
comics lesen computerspiele spielen und
da ist ganz natürlich dass ich natürlich
da auch sohn lars und kultur drum herum
entwickelt und ich steht längst nicht
mehr im gegensatz zur digitalen welt
viele verlage stellen ihre spiele
anleitung als videos ins netz
mischt nun alle anderen karten außer der
luchs karte und gibt jedem spieler 13
karten nimmt sie so oft die hand dass
die mitspieler sie nicht einsehen können
und auch bei den brettspielen selbst
macht sich ein hauch virtualität
bemerkbar etwa bei dem klassiker
scotland yard hier unterstützt eine
dazugehörige app die spieler bei ihrer
jagd nach mister rx populär sind auch
spiele cafés sogenannte ludothek etwa
die spielwiese in berlin für einen euro
in der stunde kann man sich hier aus dem
fundus von etwa 2.000 brettspielen
bedienen
michael schmidt hat das café vor zehn
jahren eröffnet am anfang war die
resonanz durchwachsen doch seit zwei
jahren ist das interesse deutlich
gestiegen
spiele café ist eine alternative zur
kneipe zum kino zum klub also ich habe
ganz ganz viele kunden die gerade so am
wochenende bis bis zum ende hier spielen
und die dann weiter zurück
die jährlich in deutschland verliehene
auszeichnung spiel des jahres gilt
mittlerweile global als eine art
brettspiel oscar ein anwärter auf den
titel 2016 ist dann vielleicht auch
benjamin täufers zum und royal